you chose option C when the bungee  jumper is going fastest I think this  will be one of the most common answers  but unfortunately it's also incorrect we  need to make a clear distinction between  velocity and acceleration velocity is  how fast something's going while  acceleration is the rate at which  velocity changes when the jumper is  going his fastest his acceleration is  actually zero after he jumps off the  platform he speeds up to a maximum  velocity at Point C but now the rope  starts slowing him down  so Point C he's neither speeding up nor  slowing down his velocity is not  changing so his acceleration is zero